rustle Ghul has ordered you return I'm
not going back I can't hey youtubers
it's Charlie this week on arrow we got
our first time with the League of
Assassins through Black Canary and we
got our freak of the week in the
dollmaker let's do a super quick recap
and then talk about which plots got
advanced so the freak of the week is
Barton Mathis he's dollmaker in the DC
Universe he actually got his start in
DC's new 52 in that series he basically
tried to turn Batman into a doll and in
this episode he's basically turning
young women into dolls and a follow up
to the events from the last episode the
Black Canary literally jumps in to the
story through the ceiling and helps
Oliver but she doesn't say why she just
runs off since the doll maker thread is
much more real Oliver actually puts Roy
on Black Canary duty though naturally he
ends up getting captured and getting his
ass kicked
what we do actually end up finding those
that the Black Canary has ties to the
League of Assassins we knew they were
going to be on the show this year and we
don't know quite how they're going to
enter Starling city but we do know that
Black Canary is their connection right
now we don't know if they have any
connections to summer Glaus character
that might be unrelated but hopefully
we'll find out in the next couple of
episodes this episode basically moved
that plot forward and the League of
Assassins is actually going to give us
our big bad this season it's not Ra's al
Ghul like they mentioned in this episode
I think that was just a little
fanservice
it's actually going to be someone else
from that organization either way Laurel
backed off of the arrows asked yeah
that's right they're calling him arrow
I feel like Smallville waited way too
long to say the S word and the payoff
just wasn't there but if you remember in
that second episode Laurel actually said
that she didn't care about the Black
Canary that's gonna change so Black
Canary is gonna be a much bigger part of
the story going forward now the
showrunners did say that most of our
interaction with the Black Canary will
be through Roy's character and through
laurels character the Oliver's going to
be spending most of his time with Summer
Glau and dealing with the freaks of the
week it didn't really address the issue
of laurels character being the black
Canary's identity in the DC Universe and
this caity lotz person being Black
Canary on the show but hopefully that'll
be explained as the season progresses
overall I didn't think the episode was
quite as strong as the premiere the
villain the dollmaker wasn't really that
strong of a character and the Black
Canary character isn't really much of a
character right now she's so
underdeveloped I feel like this is just
a hallmark of the 22 episode season
wherein showrunners just kind of have to
give themselves a place to go so the
writers can't give away too many things
too fast otherwise there won't be any
secrets to reveal at the end of the
season but
don't you think of the Black Canary
character so far and how is Roy's
character going to get tangled up with
her as the season progresses remember we
also get to see the Suicide Squad this
season we're also gonna meet the flash
in several episodes and not the
Smallville version of the flash the
full-on
Barry Allen version of the flash and we
still need to meet our Big Bad
officially meet our big bag obviously we
know it's going to come from the League
of Assassins so get excited
this season arrow is actually gonna be
really really cool either way tomorrow
morning I'll also be posting my recap
for American Horror Story coven be sure
to subscribe to get it since there's no
Legend of Korra this Friday either I'm
going to be posting a special Game of
Thrones Halloween video I'm also getting
ready to hit 30,000 subscribers so just
as a way to say thank you I thought it'd
be fun to do a Halloween themed video if
there's anything you thought was really
important in this episode that I didn't
mention the video be sure to write it in
the comments and we'll discuss if I as
always if you really want to help me out
please like and share this video thank
you so much for watching you can click
here to watch all my other arrow season
2 videos and you can click here to watch
my American Horror Story coven video
thank you so much I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you